after getting her heart completely
broken by bachelor Ben Higgins
Jojo Fletcher's journey to find love on
The Bachelorette has officially begun et
is counting down the most buzzworthy
moments of the first night from steamy
to uncomfortably awkward
first up limo exit Nick B is definitely
on our naughty list
speaking of naughty the men were on one
during Monday's premiere John the half
Scottish half Chinese suitors showed up
in a kilt and revealed this I'm half
Scottish blow boys and then there was
will the 26 year-old suitor who gave
Jojo hopefully the first and the last
unromantic ly awkward kiss of the season
I don't think I was ready for the kiss
well but no pun intended she was ready
for this steamy moment with the
incredibly hot former football pro
Jordan Rogers now that is a kid and
jojos first impression Rose went to
Rodgers and that tush his but his but I
gotta start doing squats lastly a blast
from Bachelor past interrupted JoJo's
first rose ceremony making us all think
he was there vying for her love
for you and I want you to find love here
that was close
can't wait to see what happens next week
you